[Musique]
c'est
quelque chose qui se vend très facilement sur le
marché noir
et les agriculteurs subissent une très grosse
perte
avec le vol dans leurs fermes
[Musique] [
Musique]
d'accord
dans le passé, c'était généralement
une situation où les gens
venaient  voler les fruits et les vendre
à côté de la route
de nos jours, ils sont lavés, emballés
dans des boîtes appropriées expédiées
avec un transport approprié vers
les marchés appropriés et les marchés organisés, même
[Musique]
si cette sanction peut être
difficile pour les personnes qui prennent des choses
[Musique]
euh inconditionnellement  c'est alors que nous serons en sécurité,
mais tant que la sanction est
légère,
tout le monde viendra vous voir et fera
ce que vous voulez
pour qu'il provienne du gouvernement.
plus de fruits nous devons emballer, plus
nous avons besoin de capacité chez les conditionneurs  plus
nous devons employer de personnes
ayant des risques tels que le vol d'avocats qui
affectent directement ces personnes en termes
d'emploi